yun jin roo who is three in one 2.51
era he's having a tremendous season sign
is a free agent
so there's one away and that will bring
up luke boyd
hit in the air to deep left that ball is
high it is far
it is gone luke voight
voigt hits one to detroit and that's
probably the right direction the right
direction
he is cool hand luke he homers to left
and the yankees take an immediate
one-nothing lead here is aaron hicks
switching to batting right
and the fastball swung on and hit in the
air to deep left
it is high it is far it is gone
so we begin the game as hicks hits one
to the sticks
we begin the game with voight and hicks
going back to back and a belly to belly
and the yankees take a two-nothing lead
so on the hill is jordan montgomery
is two and two in an array of 5.76
two nothing yankees one on one out here
is rowdy toles
back to the plate and a curveball laced
past the dive of the first baseman
voigton up the right field line
grazer a long run to dig it out of the
corner biggio scores
easily rowdy's on his way to second with
an rbi double
two down two on blue jays trailing 2-1
in the first jonathan vr is playing in
his eighth game with toronto
now the o2 to vr and the pitch is hit in
the air to center field not deep
hicks back a few steps makes the catch
to end the unit
so here is santiago espinal shaw at
second nobody out in the 3-2
hit right back up the middle base it
into center field travis shaw turns the
corner at third he's coming to the plate
the throw from hicks is not in time shaw
scores to tie the game
on an rbi base hit by santiago espinal
the yankees don't have to but they're
going to play their infield in for cavan
vizier
grounded oh what a play by voight he'll
take the out at first
and that keeps espinal over at third he
took a base hit away from vizio
here's randall grichik in a fly ball to
left field his first time up
and the pitch is grounded to short the
long throw to first
is perfect from torres and that will end
the inning
travis shaw comes up with two on and two
out
and the two one swung on and lined on
one hop to second
estrada from shallow right makes the
play to first in time
and montgomery scrambles out of a a
tough spot
here's the 1-0 to miggy swung on and
rip to deep left center it is high it is
far
it is gone maggie
miguel and duhar just lofted one to deep
left center field
the dew can do and
and get miggy with it and the yankees
take a 3-2 lead
here is red-hot rowdy now holder is set
to go
and the pitch cut out of this struck
about swing fastball up in the zone at
92
no runs no hits
there's clint frazier and he's over two
reese on an e5
line drive that's a base hit down the
left field line that's going to go into
the corner
lemayo will score easily boyd will stop
at third no they're waving him home
here's the throw here's the play he's
safe
a two-run double for frasier and it is
five two yankees
the batter is miguel and duhar ryu looks
in
stairs towards spurs picks up the target
and deals a swing at a miss at a
curveball
anduhar goes into the glove in the
inning comes to a close we're hidden gin
ryu
so with two down it'll be up to travis
shaw who has doubled and grounded out
now here's the 2-2 coming to shaw with a
baserunner at third and two men out in
the bottom of the fifth
five two yanks holder deals
caught on and missed he threw a change
down and away good pitch
and here is hicks this is a big batter
in the game yankees are up 5-2
you can imagine a base it would really
widen their lead
the 3-2 and he walked didn't even come
close that'll force in a run
and the yankees lead this one six to two
three straight walks
for reed foley two run double for
frazier last time up base is loaded
bases loaded around sean reid foley as
he deals the 2-1
and it's popped up out to center field
randall grichik underneath that waiting
on it
making the catch to retire this side and
here we go
a bases loaded situation for rowdy teles
now the 3-2 pitch let's bounce it
towards first base knocked down by boyd
now he has to track it down now he won't
have a play
everybody's safe and a run will score
the bases are loaded
vladimir guerrero jr is coming up
first pitch fastball and a bouncer gets
by void into right field
and two runs are going to come into
score
teles around the third guerrero takes
one the other way for a two-run
single and it's a one-run game can
lourdes goriel
keep the line moving the 1-1 pitch
swinging a line drive into left field
down for a base hit
here comes toles to tie the game up to
third goes guerrero
on an rbi single by lourdes gorilla jr
and travis shaw coming up bases loaded
the 1-2 pitch
swinging a line drive base hit into
right center field
hicks will cut it off in the alley
guerrero scores to give the blue jays
the lead
guriel is right behind him the blue jays
have come
all the way back to take the lead on a
two-run single by travis shaw
jansen is the 11th hitter of this sixth
inning
and a drive left center field
jensen clears the bases and it's a 10
run inning for the blue jays
danny jansen with his fourth home run of
the season
and kevin biggio will come to the plate
here's the o2 breaking ball is cut out
in this
but here is and duhar
ground ball is short that'll score a run
[Music]
for an rbi for and frazier scores
torres moves to third and it's now 12-7
here's brett gardner brett is over four
with two strikeouts
runner at third the 1-1 pitch ground
ball towards the middle of the diamond
vr on the backhand sets up
throws to first the scoop by tolez in
time to finish the ball game
and the toronto blue jays have a
comeback for the ages tonight